and let's switch back to the to the
English and let's uh today let's
consider something you might have seen
already in your uh in your exercises you
were generating some random numbers you
were trying to plot them see how they
how they behave uh so maybe with this
with this training uh let's consider
this example we have a several samples
so several times we roll a dice we uh
take a measurement of a temperature of a
pressure of of anything and we for each
experiment Mark the corresponding value
um what would you have guessed uh would
be would be an
appropriate uh the two parameters mean
and uh standard deviation for for the
data for the distribution ution that
generated this this
data maybe should be one yeah okay it
looks it looks like it should be should
be somewhere somewhere around one okay
and what about the what about the
standard deviation
it's not going to be an exotic number
yeah I mean I was generating it in
Matlab and I didn't put any any special
like half of the pie or or
anything or maybe how we could how we
could guess that uh let's back let's go
back to to our uh to one two three uh
Sigma
Sigma bands so what we have derived
calculated last week was that within
plusus three standard
deviation there should be basically
9973 so almost all values that that we
can now now get should should lie in
this in this band
so this is the test to your IM
imagination uh first whether you can
transfer this this uh this
concept so where
would what is the band where most of the
values would lie so plusus
0.3 plus minus 0.3 yeah well so minus
that's that's okay 0 1.3 is there so
there maybe maybe two two values which
are which are just uh just slightly off
with what is it thousand samples yeah we
can we can allow some of these values to
be uh to be of uh of this of this band
so okay so if this band is uh the whole
one is 0.6 or half of it is 0
0.3 and we would say okay these are the
three standard deviations so one
standard deviation is
01 exactly that's what that's what gener
generated this this distribution okay
perfect so this is a trivial trivial
example just to just to motivate and uh
it's going to be uh going going to
become less and less trivial as we go by
but uh let's uh let's just first say
that uh we are dealing with the with the
problem of uh u i just wred down
first we want
to that was a bad
one we just want to estimate a
constant estimation of
a constant
in other words we just want to find out
the mean and not only that as we will we
will proceed today we would also look at
the how this how how what are the what
are the properties uh of this of this
mean what is uh what is going on as we
are taking more and more samples so
basically
the the picture
um this is good
no at the end of our of our journey just
simple simp very simple very simple
problem we would like
to we would like to approximate this is
the data that we that we measured let's
say that we just want to that we just
want to calculate this this constant and
okay now it's obvious and and visible uh
we will look at uh what's going to
happen if we are taking maybe we don't
want to take all the Thousand samples in
the in the beginning maybe we just take
first 10 samples and we estimate the
mean how much we are of we take for
another 40 samples so we have 50 samples
in total how much we are of if we
calculate mean mean from
this uh from this uh subset of the of
the
data so
our basically
our estimate uh of the let's let's call
it y our our
constant should
should somehow tend to the to the mean
or we can we can call it with this y
head
notation y uh y bar notation yeah let's
say that Y Bar is our is our one we are
rolling a dice measuring temperature and
we are we are trying to estim estimate
this so our estimate of this of this
constant so it will be why the head is
there for for estimate will actually
actually change with time we'll see it
in a in a second and
uh we are basically trying to trying to
find like our we are trying to get a get
a
model which we can which we can write
right in in in this
way if our data will obey the normal
distribution so whenever there is some
discrepancy some error in the data it
will come from gausian or normal
distribution then our our model is a
statistical model very simple one so we
assume that the true
uh
[Music]
true true constant y that we try to
estimate is going to be the mean that we
estimated plus some error that we get
because we don't didn't do million of of
experiments so it's either going to be
that we say
that that we say that
sorry why our our random variables are
our random measurements are distributed
in what way we have H they obey the
there is a mean value Y Bar which we
potentially never never get the true
value of and there's a and there is
some some
variance or or standard
deviation the only trick that uh that
this um this relation tries to tries to
tries to do is to uh somehow slightly
standardize this uh this normal
distribution because if we if we do it
do it this way then what happens what we
can say about the about this e our
error well our our error will then will
then
be normal distribution we already took
care about the mean we will estimate it
and and uh and so this error will have a
zero mean and and some again uh standard
deviation
just uh just all about all about uh
notation
here uh maybe let's
also also draw this with
some with some
simpler simpler notation so let's say in
time we are getting some
measurements um
we can start by saying like yeah there
is a measurement of time T1 T2 T3 if we
if we want we can go to a uh
slightly slightly simpler notation you
will uh you will see something like that
in your theory of automatic control you
will switch to discrete time systems
very
soon so this is
so in instead of just uh just uh writing
T all the time we basically just just
write this uh these
subscripts
uh yeah so basically just the same
thing we can now even get rid of this
notion of time and let's just say this
was the experiment number one experiment
number two experiment number number
three and so
on so if there is no noise in our in our
measurements this is
our our true value of the of the
constant if there was no noise in our
measurements then basically in all three
experiments we would consistent ly
consistently measure the current
temperature in this in this room for
example since there is noise of course
we expect some troubles to troubles to
arise so
we basically
measure measure for example something
like this yeah this this uh these dots
here and now it's uh not that not that
apparent anymore well if we if we
calculate the mean out of this well we
don't uh don't really get the the black
line or the or the value at at y
bar right maybe if we calculate
the the
mean no
since we measured two two data points
which are above the above this constant
above the the desired value maybe maybe
our estimated mean after this these
three measurements would be just uh just
slightly
off
okay
uh very very simple Quest we are up uh
for to today so the question is where
where we can use it uh we have some uh
example in your in your
exercises uh for example you can you can
think of uh our good old body the the
torich torich law let's say if we have a
if we have a tank
and the
standard standard our example where we
can where we can measure the the height
uh and we can measure some some outflow
outflow Q well maybe we have no idea how
this how this valve is going to to
behave uh what is the what is this
constant of a of a valve so we might set
up an experiment and uh we can uh
collect the the data let's say
we have
several uh several
experiments I don't know one two three
then we have then we measure height in
this in these three experiments we
measure flow rate in this in these three
experiments
so in principle if we if we now uh do
what if we want to estimate estimate the
constant of of a valve from from these
values what what can we do how can we
calculate
it if I just now I know Q I know H I
know the flow rate I know the the height
how how do I get the get the constant of
a
valve yeah exactly exactly we divide Q
by the square root of square root of
H oh the handwriting is okay ah that was
nice H I
hope well and we again get here some
some values and basically this this one
that we that we just
got
well it's quite possible that it might
start looking looking like like this
yeah there will be several several
experiments or maybe if we do three
experiments it would it would look like
this oh let's let's try finding the
statistically best possible value let's
try somehow making sense out of this
of course simil similar thing uh maybe
uh if you uh follow the if you will um
experiment with some devices try to
estimate uh The Standard Time constants
or or the static gains of some of some
uh transfer functions well what can you
what can you
do you can
[Music]
if there if we have uh so static
gain static gain of some of some
transfer function would
be could be easily easily defined
defined this way I'm only using I do
bunch of Step tests or I know bunch of
uh steady state values of the of the
output and I know bunch of the the state
corresponding uh values of the of the
input so uh again I have I have a column
of how much did I change the input I
have a column how much the output
changed and and I can again get get some
value of a of a time constant if the
system is nonlinear the time constant is
not going to be not going to be even
even unique if there are some
measurement noises we are again in one
of these situ equations that uh our data
will not show only one consistent value
yeah good so what to do in such a case
these are images for later I just move
them here uh so what to do uh we can
even try
uh well what would you what would you
do when we talk about since we talk
about the statistics what how would you
process this
data I got five
5.1
4.7 and and six and I want and I and I
want just one number out of this sorry I
misclicked something here and I just
want a single number which would
represent which would ideally predict
what uh what happens what do I
do mean mean yeah mean in in some in
some way uh because there are actually
multiple ways of course
naturally uh naturally we will we will
think about
Ari arithmetic
mean right so
in in
general I have uh
oops I have my data and my data are just
like y1 Y
2 and so on until let's say one y
capital
N now so how do we how do we find our
our
estimate easy yeah we know we have a
capital N number of of the
data 1/ n we have done this done this
last time we sum from one until n all
these all these data
points so so let's see and and test
whether whether this mean is uh is fine
or whether there there cannot be some
other mean that could uh that could work
is there some other mean that you that
you know weighted mean weighted mean is
uh is a is a type of the of the
arithmetic mean when we basically try to
start to Vari this this number
number uh yeah it's a logiic mean logari
geometric mean is a is a is a good
one
geom geometric mean how can that be
written we will we will see it here in a
in a
second so in that case
our how is how how is our
estimate how what's the formula for the
for the GE geometri
mean you recall
no so we are not adding numbers we are
multiplying numbers yes that's the
that's the first thing so y1 * y y 2 I
time YN
and uh since we multiplied B bunch of
these in order to get even the even the
same um same unit of of our estimate we
need to take
a some root yeah we would take the end
end
root uh maybe you remember in your
theory of automatic control you used the
one property y of the geometric and
arithmetic mean you were trying to find
out whether uh whether the step response
of the two tanks will ever be periodic
and uh do you recall that there there
was there was one one property uh which
is basically comparing the arithmetic
and the and the geometric geometric mean
and how is it arithmetic is always
greater or equal than geometric or
geometric is always greater or equal
than
arithmetic which one this is a quick
poll so who's for who's for option
A hands
up two four
six that's up or down okay seven and the
geometric mean is than the than than the
than the rest uh let's see but I think
it's the the first option was was
correct
um okay let's get another
page
and we will compare these two that's
what the what this uh pictures are are
showing and uh we will compare them with
uh with one more that was uh it got uh
wide media attention during the covid
pandemic because we had the 7 Days uh
median of the incidence of covid-19 so
let's uh let's try to also see
median how is how is median calculated
what's the what's the
formula I don't know formula but it
should be the middle
okay uh
so let's not do the formula but let
Let's do an algorithm yeah it's also
sort of a sort of a formula so if you
have this uh what was what was our
example 4 4.8 uh
4.5
5.1 and so on uh how would you how would
you uh process see if if these y's are
the are the different
measurements how would you program
it not bad right so we so we sort yeah
so we get
some y1 Tilda Y 2 Y 2 Tilda
until so some sort so in in our in our
example uh what's the median here 4.8
4.8 okay yakob is is today answering for
for all of us okay yeah so if we sort
what what's going to happen so this 4.5
will will precede the will precede the
four 4.8
right and then
what maybe the amount of the values one
two to get
the uh okay if you have million values
it's going to be a bit
impractical then
maybe according
the amount
of is even or uneven good one yes yes
even even even even or OD yes okay so if
uh n
is n is even that's harder part so if n
is odd write it a
bit so is if n is odd then our y let's
call it
m will be will be just what I have I
have this Vector of of million values
and I know there are n of them so
I so
the the n n would
be n + 1
be n + 1 / 2 right
mik does not seem
convinced you believe it okay so let's
do the quick test on this very general
example uh of course just just the short
one so we have n is three n + 1 is four
divided by two we are we are getting two
so we pick the second element of this of
this vector
yeah that's good and okay let's say that
let's say that we have this uh this
situation that now the N is even what's
going to
happen so there could be two values that
could be Med but I think it should be
defined as
N2 so be the first of the n n SL2 I
think what what most of the
implementation uh do they would say okay
well they are not that not that
different uh but uh if in in case there
are there there is still slight
difference we we would take the average
so it's actually how it's going to look
like we
take the n
how it's going to look like we want to
get the average of these two so this
position is n ided by two right so n
half n half
+ n half + 1 divided by divided by two
yeah that would be our our
median so this guy here this guy
here maybe I can take the consistent
colors okay yellow
[Music]
color this is how it's going to be born
the arithmetic mean will
be let's say it's blue okay
maybe something like this like
arithmetic geometri
mean red
one okay
good we made it and La let's now put
these uh these three variants to to to
test how do we put it to to test let's
first let's first
see enlarge perfect let's first see
what's uh what's going to
happen the same data set of these blue
crosses we we saw before is just
slightly shaded such that we we see a
bit uh bit better is now is now taken
and uh what we what we do here we really
estimate as the samples are coming
sometimes it's called on the Fly EST
estimation uh don't worry there is a
better zoomed picture I just wanted you
you to see the the the the perspective
that it's really really looks like we
are visibly visibly off so every time
this arithmetic mean blue line ger mean
the the red line yellow line is the
median every time they are calculated
just based on all the samples that that
were that that we have seen since uh
since zero or since the since the first
sample okay and uh
we I don't know whether this surprises
you or or not I mean the scale is not
that not that big uh but uh what what
would you what would you conclude if you
if you
see bless you uh what would you uh
conclude if you see this uh this
behavior is uh are they doing their jobs
is it uh is everything everything fine
um is sorry
so the each
uh mean or median is calculated from how
much
points yes uh so again if yeah yeah if
we are for for the value of blue yellow
and red curve at 40 we take 400 previous
previous
samples yeah so that that's that's why
that's why why it it it happens happens
here that in the beginning since we
don't have enough samples and well
relative to the scale I mean these are
not that that big numbers but relative
to the to the scale we have quite quite
some
oscillations yeah all of them are are
kind of kind of okay uh after after some
some point some point in time What can
you also also conclude the the noise is
is much much uh much bigger than uh much
much higher than actually what what we
are getting for the for the estimated
what we are getting even for the for the
error of the of the estimate yeah we are
we are not that off even with with small
small number of the of the samples yeah
so they are all fine maybe let's uh
let's take a let's take a closer look so
the closer look I will I will enlarge it
it's just uh is it again thousand yes uh
sample estimate variance yes so we will
just now zoom into this uh what is the
band like 1
Point
0.94 yeah that's where this red one has
the has the lowest value and one 1 point
one
1.06 and we get rid of this
blue blue crosses just to just to see it
see it even better because now we can
start compare them to to each
other what would you what would you say
say
now what what do you see in the picture
what what catches your your
attention positively
negatively
geometric is
different are more close to each other I
mean
and mhm MH yeah in in the end well in
the in the beginning it it
looks not not so yes uh what else what
about uh what about our our lovely
lovely condition arithmetic mean being
always greater than than
geometric is it
fulfilled yes good yes
perfect
um so mhm
pardon high or equal yeah great greater
or equal yes yes um no it's always the
red red curve is always below below the
blue
one uh so which one does seem to seem to
do the the best job now we can
compare CL closer maybe let's say we can
take we can say like like at the end
which one is the
bestme arithmetic mean uh what about
what about before what about its overall
Behavior think about it like this is
your I don't know uh Masterpiece defense
and uh and and you want
describe describe the results that you
that you see we F I would
doal all
and which one has
thehm okay but cannot we actually guess
it it's a it's a good good
measure well integral of what so
integral like a like a difference with
respect to one right yes yes yeah so for
me it seems that this arithmetic mean is
doing doing pretty pretty good job o
over overall you might be uh
dissatisfied like H here at around 500
something it already got the correct
value and then some some samples there
were some samples coming probably higher
than than than one much higher than one
and they knocked it off for for a while
and then it then it then it returned uh
arithmetic mean seems to be seems to be
really really doing a doing a great job
and what what what you can what you can
notice the arithmetic mean it it's uh
it's not
uh it never happens okay let let's do it
by by some contrast look at the median
the the yellow line yeah it's seems like
okay it is settling settling down and
then something knocks it off yeah there
is some some violent Behavior like some
disturbance to your to your controller
which doesn't affect these are the same
data taken yeah so it doesn't affect the
the arithmetic mean so there is some
property in the arithmetic mean that
also makes it to meander less and less
to be more and more confident as the
more samples are are
taken
um also we can we can notice this
behavior in the in the beginning like
this median is getting getting quite
quite off but uh all of them are are
getting off it's just the problem with
the small small sample
sizes
um let's do some some some sort of a
statistics on this so let's now
observe just just this point which means
we will always not now take arithmetic
geometric mean and the median of
thousand samples and we will do this
thousand times
so in there is a code for this in the
e-learn you can you can find find it
easily and try it so thousand times we
generate this situation new data to see
how they how they perform that's a real
real statistics like it's thousand races
yeah this was you can think of this as a
these guys the arithmetic mean geometric
mean median they were just running One
race so it's not fair to say like one is
better than than the other we can go we
can do much better we generate thousand
times thousand data points and we and we
compare so let's see what we can what we
get uh oh no this is
move
perfect maybe like this I I hope it's
still visible tell me tell me if
not we will have some uh specific uh
specific visualization here common in in
in in statistics uh we have haven't seen
you haven't seen it seen it yet but uh
but you but you but you've seen it from
a from a different angle uh so this so
sort of a box plot how is
it how how is it obtained
um let's just
if I would have my ah normal
distribution
okay let's say I have my normal
distribution and this is let's say the
performance now I measured I took the
first th000 points I I measured that the
uh that the what do we have here the
mean that we estimated let's just put it
there
correctly
the mean that we estimated whether it's
arithmetic geometric or the or the or
the median well we get we get thousand
samples so we can do
histograms well we can we can get this
sort of statistics so the
histograms histograms you have you have
already already seen and now we can
estimate what is the mean error
or most most probable value that the
arithmetic mean will capture once it see
once it saw thousand
samples yeah so this is the
this is the the estimate so the red line
here corresponds with the with the red
bar here the rest of the plot is you can
imagine it as taking this histogram this
curve and turning it and then just
visualizing like in this in this box
there is there is the top of top of this
hill
rising and uh and and the and the box is
not uh just somebox it actually uh
brings us back to the distribution
function it would
mark it would Mark
[Music]
uh let's call it like
this it would Mark the point where the
cumulative distribution function will
will reach uh the value of
0.25 in other
words there is
25% of the of the race results of the of
the arithmetic uh what is below of the
of the arithmetic uh arithmetic
geometric and and median which are below
this this value Yeah so basically there
is 25% of the day of the of
the uh of the of the values that they
reached
after after getting the the Thousand
samples and doing the mean and the so
the box is a box for the for this reason
so what we could expect here this is a
75% % so there is there is 25% here
below 25% below that marks this to be
the 75% so here we would find 50% of the
of the outcomes yeah so it's it's quite
dense so the arithmetic mean for example
has a 50% chance that its error would
would be uh let's say between would be
around what 0 point
0 0 maybe three yeah plus minus 0 0 0 03
yeah make
sense I like skeptical pH of of
Marik
okay if if if you are uh feeling L with
that let let me know let me know uh
what
about what about the the rest this uh
this uh black black lines black bars uh
basically they would uh they would say
what is the what is the spread of the of
the data points so there was within this
interval there was some race there there
was a one result of a of of a race uh
race happening so they Med Ian there was
some case where median reached at the
end of the Thousand samples run 0
98 983 yeah it it failed to estimate the
the number
one
uh yes basically basically that's it for
for how this plot was uh was
reached if it's
if it's clear then let's go back
and so let's now try
to uhuh this is not good okay so let's
now try try
to uh try to see what is what is going
on so which one is the best which one is
the worst why
why
because it's mean is closest to one and
the range is small mhm yeah yeah so it's
the most most probable is the is is that
uh uh it uh it reaches uh it reaches the
value of one if exposed to, samples that
comes from this distribution and also
it's a the 50 there is a 50% chance that
the error won't be larger than
0.3
okay what else what about the geometric
mean what would you what would you
comment on on this how would you assess
the behavior does it make sense is it
good
bad the value is a little bit off it's
smaller than
arithmetic but the range is similar yeah
yeah basically it's uh what what we what
we see is is just again arithmetic mean
being greater or equal than geometric
mean and uh
oh yeah and this is basically it's like
a it's like a copy paste with the with
with just lower lower
values and uh the uh winner last and
also least so
the sorry the the the worst one appears
to be to be
median in some
respect which respect what do what do
you think is happening
there the value is correct but
range value is correct okay so uh it's
still sorry most probable that uh that
it will that it will reach uh reach the
value value of one but it's also quite
probable or more more probable that it
that it will have error larger than the
than the arithmetic mean yeah that's
what the size of the of the Box tells
us and uh of course this this spread is
the is the largest am among all so we
can get it's possible not very likely
but possible to to be off by what is it
uh
0.02 almost yeah so with th samples with
a nice behaving uh data as we have this
might be a this might be a bit bit too
much okay so we will you will try to
construct this in your in your examples
uh okay maybe this uh the widespread of
the of the median is uh could be
attributed to the to exactly this kind
of uh behavior of this of this uh of
this teeth that
uh um one one sample can change which of
the which of the values are are taken in
into this into this formula so one
sample uh triggers that that this the
median is is using another another
numbers yeah if you if you look at the
median it's based on one or one or two
numbers while while the arithmetic mean
and the and the geometric mean they they
they take values of each numbers much
more into into
account so before we go to the
completely statistical approach uh let's
uh let's let's
try an approach which will be based on
based on
optimization optimization based
approach and this is the approach you
are quite familiar with you have you
have seen it as the least uh squares uh
Le squares
estimation how can we tell me how can we
formulate so we have uh couple of couple
of data points capital N of data points
how can we formulate the the Le squares
uh problem we are again trying to find
the
Y hat yeah some estimate of this of this
constant in comparison with the mean and
Med
um forget about arithmetic mean
geometric mean let's just let's just
again uh again see this problem so we
have bunch of data points and we want to
find y
head yeah that's our that's that's our
question we will we will we will try to
find some parameter
M and we have to make summation
of okay yeah minimization with respect
to Y hat sum of y i - y hat
squar and the sum goes from I = to 1
until until n yeah that's that's a
number that's a number of our of our
data
points sounds like a nice nice little
little problem how do we how do we solve
it
numerically how do you solve this
numerically PR it's it's it's quite hard
because we we we just we just have here
some bunch of letters
yeah that's what I remember my I have
one one friend he never never went to
University education but he once uh
visited my lecture in in Germany and he
said like yeah okay you are doing
mathematics but not with numbers with
the letters so then we have to solve it
analytically very
good making
gradient well taking a derivative it's a
what what type of optimization is is
that you had a bunch of bunch of time B
bunch of types
uh multidimensional scaler unconstrained
constrainted it's a
unconstrained
optimization problem with one variable
with one variable scaler optimization
yeah so I mean there are numerical
methods but yeah not even a gradient
just derivative yeah because gradient
would already apply to to
multi-dimensional but yes correct so and
uh what the what the gradient should
obey should be equal to
zero right we are trying to find the
extreme so how how is how how does the
derivative look
like yeah just remain silent and some
somebody somebody will we'll we'll pick
that
up okay two the bracket two times the
bracket what about the
sum
oh but it's easy yeah the derivative of
the sum is
the sum of the derivatives okay yeah so
sum of the
derivatives and how are the derivatives
twice
the bracket as as M said yes we have
some minus one uh we can do a bit bit of
Tidy Up
um I mean this uh so whatever is not
does whatever does not have index
I uh can be uh and it's and it's in
multiplication uh in in product with the
with the rest can be taken out of the
sum right so we can take the two in in
front of the sum we can take the minus
one in front of the sum but we have zero
on the left hand side so what we can
what we can do even
easier we can we can get get rid of this
right how to get rid of this
oh if we
just we just multiply by Min - one2 or
we divide by minus 2 now so what we are
left with this
sum and what y
IUS y
hat
okay what next maybe we should now
divide this bracket how to how or divide
separate this this
bracket TR making two SS mhm
exactly from I = 1 to n of y i and then
we have
minus okay let's write it as a as a
sum but then we will see we can get we
can make it simplified
this one is fine I don't see any
simplification possible but this one can
be
simplified
how ignore
it yeah and and what so if I and and
what to write instead of it
that that wouldn't that wouldn't be
equal right because because it says like
uh uh take one banana one banana one
banana until you get n bananas yeah so
there is
no yeah but it's still still the sum it
it has to go through all the all the
values
but yes yes change but you still have to
edit the end yes yeah so there are two
[Music]
to two two two versions the version
which yakob is up for is to say well we
are adding and times yeah there is one
banana second banana third banana until
we we get to n bananas yes so we
calculated uh so we uh summed n bananas
together yeah this won't be won't be
won't be equal mhm
all
right okay so let's then try to tiey up
again
y1 minus
n and let's let's see uh what are we
looking for
why y
hat mhm how do we get y
[Music]
hat right so
the yeah everybody sees that right I
take the N times y head on to the light
to the left hand side it becomes Plus
and then I divide what what remained on
the on the right hand side
[Music]
mhm perfect
so arithmetic
mean is is an answer what was the
question
the so we got the arithmetic mean that
was the the question
was which of the
which number would be would
represent bunch of the bunch of the data
points such that we minimize the the the
distance we
actually what we what we got in in the
lecture let's just flip there oh no
what we got in in our in our lecture
lecture last week well this is
basically this is basically a a variance
the standard standard deviation
deviation squared so we are trying to
Trying to minimize it yeah so that's why
that's why it can yeah this is nothing
else than doing the doing the minim
minimization of the of the variance of
the of the estimate so our arithmetic
mean behaves so well compared compared
to the median because it it tries to
tries to
minimize right it also tries to tries to
minimize the the the variance the the
error error
itself okay so we have some uh knife
approach with just trying to guess
arithmetic mean geometric mean median we
already see saw some optimization based
approach and now we
will now we will move uh towards uh the
statistical approach and in
the approach
so in the statistical
approach we start from the from the same
same ground we have couple of data
points and uh we embrace the fact that
these data points are
coming with some coming from some normal
distribution with
the mean value Y Bar and with the with
some variance or standard
deviation
the
distinguishing fact will will now be
that uh we want
to now take the N samples and we want to
find the most probable value that would
represent these uh these
samples so for for this um what we have
seen so far we have seen
[Music]
our our PDF our um probability density
function and uh let me now
say let's just let's just do some some
notation yeah if the K is the ordinal
number of our experiment K y1 is the
first experiment Y2 is the second
experiment so basically each of the
capital N number of
experiments are we are getting the this
value with some probability and what
stati statisticians usually usually
write is uh like this uh this data point
or or this data so what is the
probability of seeing this uh this data
point given data point given that's the
that's this uh standing slash that's
this pole for given
that the that the probability density
function is encoded with these two
parameters yeah the mean and
the mean and uh and the
variance and
uh this is okay but it's not not quite
uh helpful for for our case because our
case is uh is actually different yeah
it's other way way around we are given
some data and we are trying to find well
we can either find the the mean and in
the statistical approach we will soon
find out we can also find the find
variance
so uh for this uh we actually can use
the very same mathematical function it's
just uh it will be given a given a
different different name so if we just
say that we
have given some parameters
we are now asking uh sorry no we are not
given the parameters we are now given
the data and we are just asking what is
the likelihood what is the probability
of uh of this data to be generated by
some distribution that has the mean y
head and the standard deviation
Sigma so let's say
let's say like this I mean not nothing
nothing really changes it's still this
is still our good old uh good old
gaan gaan function gaan probability
distribution okay let me write it
yeah we still have 1 / Sigma square otk
of 2 pi e to the minus and maybe we can
now express it in the way that that we
took this values
[Music]
in so YK minus the mean SAR / 2 to the
to the sign
squared it's nothing really fancy it's
just
uh it's just a different name so this
uh this function is uh is called
likelihood
function
oops
likely Hood
function don't know whether you train
some neural networks or or stuff like
that before sometimes they they will
tell you like a log likelihood function
is this and that we'll we'll soon find
out what's what's going to
happen good
so we are still still not there yet we
have now just established
like a way of saying what is the
contribution of some data point to to to
the value of the mean and the and the
standard
deviation uh we are basically in a
situation that now we can measure the
measure the probability if we guess y
head and sigma then uh then we can then
we can find out okay the likelihood of
that uh y head and Y Bar and sigma given
the data point y k is this end that yeah
so basically we have like
[Music]
L 4 y1 yeah because that's the number
that we measured yeah that's one of the
blue
crosses we have the same
sorry same thing for the Y 2 and dot dot
dot
yeah so for all of our now we can either
guess the Y Bar Sigma and evaluate what
are the
probabilities of the data points given
these
parameters and that is not helpful
either because well now we now we know
again bunch of numbers but if we guess
correctly we can guess we can get like
the statistically best answer for all of
the data points so this is the same
situation of like I roll the dice once I
roll the dice second time I roll it
third times fourth time and so on now
now I want to want to calculate
something something jointed so some
that will make make the outcomes of
these experiments to be to be the most
likely that's why uh that's why we are
also also uh talking about
the ah what's the word where are my
notes uh how is it called maximum
likelihood estimation
maximum
likelihood estimation don't know whether
you whether you you you've you've seen
that uh but well it appears in in bunch
of the in bunch of the occasions once
you once you do like machine learning
and stuff okay so for maximum likelihood
estimate
we need to get out of these several
several tosses of a coin several throws
of the of the dice we need to get like a
single number we need to we need to say
okay if event a happen what is the
probability that also the event B
happened what is the what is the
probability so this is what we what we
have done done last time uh so what is
the probability of a a and b what
if I throw number one on the dice and in
my second trial I threw number number
one again what is the probability of
this happening if I know the probability
of rolling a and the and the probability
well of probability of of the event a
rolling a dice and event b r rolling a
dice how can we find The Joint
probability it's
multiplication
probabil we did the
foreshadowing foreshadowing right last
time yeah exactly so it's a
* a *
B good now now these
probabilities are this are this capital
L's so what we what we need to find
out we will post this again as an
optimization problem and we will try to
it says maximum likelihood we'll try
to find out the two parameters that will
maximize the probability the
likelihood The Joint probability that
will be given
as well we have these single
probabilities how did we call
them Y Bar Sigma
given given some y k and since we are
multiplying all of them together well we
use use the product from k equal 1 until
until capital
N
okay and this is going to take more than
five or five or 10 minutes maybe 12 but
uh let's uh let's continue on this uh on
this uh next time so we are getting this
Cliffhanger
weather weather by I taking so just to
just for you to to now see what what we
have what kind of a beast now we want to
take the
maximization we we are trying to find
two two values maximization of the
product so we are multiplying and the
capital L what was the capital L well
the capital L is our good old gausian
function so we are now multiplying
several fractions several exponents we
will solve it analytically uh next
time any questions
comments okay if not then let's pause
our video